le bras de fer continue entre l'iran et
l'union européenne terre ans confirme
aujourd'hui son intention de reprendre
rapidement ses activités nucléaires
parallèlement à vienne l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
doit reprendre cet après midi sa réunion
le point avec bernard lebrun ouvrir un
bidon de minerai d'uranium
constitue-t-il une violation du traité
de non prolifération nucléaire
non répondent à l'unisson les diplomates
européens qui tente de jouer
l'apaisement avec l'iran nous pensons
qu'il est encore possible de négocier
nous tendons encore la main car après
tout la conversion de minerai d'uranium
en gaz n'est pas un acte sans cibles
militaires
son but est à vocation civile insistent
les iraniens afin d'alimenter en
carburant les centrales électriques
nucléaires depuis que le savoir faire
existe dans notre pays il est légal et
légitime que l'iran maîtrise la
technologie nucléaire
d'autant plus que la république
islamique d'iran contrairement à l'inde
le pakistan ou israël est membre de l'aï
à l' agence de l'onu qui contrôle
l'application du traité de non
prolifération nucléaire
bref l'apaisement est telle que l'on se
demande aujourd'hui en quoi la
provocation iranienne pose problème le
conseil de l'eeie a n'a pas réussi à se
mettre d'accord cette nuit sur un rappel
à l'ordre ou non à l'iran toujours
menacés d'une saisine du conseil de
sécurité
comme s'est empressé de le rappeler
cette nuit washington craint ce coin de
choses mais les nations unies restent
une option dans la crise avec l'iran
quand même si le nouveau président
iranien se dit prêt à revenir à la table
des négociations
bras de fer est partie d'échecs
pendant que les débats se poursuivent
cet après midi à vienne l'iran avance et
pio après le bidon de lundi téhéran
annonce vouloir lever aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des scellés sur cette usine à
combustible nucléaire
10 par an près